[Música]
bienvenidos a en 5 minutos con hoy nos
acompaña a raúl barrios licenciado en
psicología con quien abordaremos la
industria deportiva que ha encontrado en
este distanciamiento social y el
confinamiento retos en diversas áreas
hablemos de los psicológicos señor
barrios gracias nuevamente por estar con
nosotros hoy en día la mayoría de las
competiciones se celebran sin público
qué impacto puede tener en el
rendimiento de los deportistas y cuáles
son los principales desafíos que
identifica
que está algunos días un gusto estar
hablando con ustedes bueno por suerte
volvió al deporte aún en el formato al
que no estamos acostumbrados que es sin
público la presencia de público siempre
es un elemento interesante en el deporte
puede ser estresor o no depende los
recursos de afrontamiento que tenga cada
deportista este y digamos y le quita
esta cosa del folclore del espectáculo y
de las hinchadas las banderas los cantos
etcétera no obstante lo cual hay muchos
deportistas que hasta se pueden ver
favorecidos con que no vaya público éste
porque nada tienen menos directores
sienten menos estrés poder manejar
o mejorar sus estrategia de
afrontamiento en competencia este y nada
lo importante es la mayoría de los
deportistas lo que refiere como positivo
de esta vuelta independientemente del
contexto es la posibilidad de ver a
competir y de volver a entrenar con el
objetivo de competir todos los fines de
semana que es lo que estaba faltando
porque todos pudimos sospechar de alguna
manera el entrenamiento durante la
pandemia no
diversas tonalidades nuevas virtuales
vía suma etcétera pero bueno la esencia
del deporte es la competencia y la
vuelta a la competencia es lo que ha
generado digamos mucho mayor
satisfacción que el entorno si se quiere
no sí señor barrios y en qué deportes
puede impactar más esta ausencia de los
aficionados
sobre todo en aquellos deportes en donde
la localía digamos los equipos que hacen
de la localía una herramienta de
sentirse fuertes en su cancha por las
dimensiones del campo de juego por el
tipo de campo de juego por la cercanía
no del público y porque muchos equipos
la verdad que el aliento del público la
presencia del público pues puede ser
tomado como un combustible como un motor
que incrementa o potencian las
capacidades tanto físicas como
psicológico como tácticas estrategias si
bien nosotros tratamos de reducir en
términos de la percepción del deportista
el impacto es porque la verdad que es
una variable que está fuera del alcance
del deportista del deportista no puede
manejar lo que ocurre en su entorno pero
bueno algunos equipos que hacen de la
localía su fortaleza
digamos por ahí en este entorno sin
público le saca eso no le saca esa parte
que es más crucial que es más folclórica
pero bueno en definitiva en ese sentido
lo puede afectar no no no más allá de
eso digamos
sí sí señor barrios ya no se
identificaba lo importante es que es el
deporte como distracción a una sociedad
y ahora en la actualidad pues una
sociedad ya muy tensa aburrida o incluso
harta por las mías de la pandemia
considerada así señor barrios si sea
absolutamente gracioso yo me animaría
decirte que el que más sufre la falta de
público en el deporte es el público no
tanto el deportista si porque finalmente
el deportista juega libera endorfinas
genera un estado de bienestar
psicológico por la competencia
digamos la verdad es que que los que los
que padecen digamos la falta de
asistencia a las canchas es la gente así
a mí particularmente me gusta ir a la
cancha es una cosa que en su momento
hacíamos con mis hijos disfrutábamos
pero bueno me parece que el espectador
es el que más sufre con esta restricción
y no tanto el deportista digamos no y
esta nueva normalidad en el deporte que
nos identifica señor barrios como la
poca asistencia de aficionados puede
generarle más lesiones o bajo
rendimiento a los deportistas
no yo creo que por el contrario y esto
es una diferencia más bien que hago no
no hay evidencia científica al respecto
pero no yo creo que favorece el
rendimiento porque porque digamos el
deportista tiene digamos puede puede
optimizar más el uso de sus recursos es
decir seguir a la mente hay deportistas
que que se estresan ante un insulto ante
ante él este rumor que a veces sucede en
las tribunas cuando doy un mal pase o
cuando realizó una mala jugada y este
murmullo no se genera que que me puede
afectar negativamente viene al no estar
eso digamos uno puede suponer que el
deportista juega con mayor tranquilidad
no muy bien y mal lo vemos del pistón y
esto no está cerca pues muchas gracias
raúl barrios por sus palabras y sus
comentarios respecto a la psicología en
el deporte gracias a ustedes por su
compañía siga con nosotros en france 24
[Música]